play the whole day  and the black king is finally about to  get safe  you can go and pick up a pawn and  maybe one more check and we will see  Duda resign as soon as the tracks run  out  yeah the king just needs to sized up one  square  I was going to say the other direction  but uh yeah Liam's still struggling to  find safety for that black king well I  think the Queens will now provide some  shelter for the king  two coins are better than one  unfortunately for Duda and Black's other  Queen at the bottom of the board can now  jump back and block  yeah you're running out of Tricks here  it's a lot of Queens yeah that's quite  often we see  two queens teaming up to win the game  yeah I think every time we see more than  two Queens on the board it's always Duda  but there we go he does eventually admit  defeat wow his first match loss in the  tour finals young Crystal Duda this  could be a huge one for the tournament